[Music]
in any school it's vital that kids feel
safe and valued these are among the
laudable goals of social and emotional
learning or SEL but SEO advocates need
to keep in mind some crucial cautions
here or - one promoting student safety
should not turn into an excuse to push
an agenda some SEL proponents seem
particularly taken with restorative
justice and tend to overstate the
evidence that it works students should
feel safe and valued and strategies to
make that happen should be held to a
consistent empirical standard - concern
for the emotional well-being of students
cannot become a free pass for academic
folly it's healthy and natural for
parents and teachers to care how
children are doing socially and
emotionally but ultimately schools must
be places of learning SEL must remain
tightly linked to a focus on how kids
are doing academically absent these
considerations SEO risks becoming more
about adult agendas than about what kids
need do you think that school
improvement efforts usually serve the
needs of adults or kids let us know in
our poll also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI